Exploring other planets is one of mankind's most cherished dreams.
At the very beginning of the space era enthusiasts was certain that in the 21st
century, our closest planets in the solar system would be thoroughly explored.
In reality. However, things proved to be much more complicated than expected.
And so far apart from the moon and the, the earth, of course,
no human has set food on the surface of any other celestial body.
Many believe that manned flights will not pay others.
Doubt if they'll be in demand still,
there is a good chance of visiting other worlds and its closer than may seem at
first glance.
The first in outer space, the American company,
SpaceX is one of those who are essentially the tip of the spear in space
exploration.
This private commercial organization was founded by Elon Musk back in 2002,
six years after its foundation.
And after a lot of research and a number of failed experiments,
the Falcon one launch vehicle developed by SpaceX engineers successfully went
into our Earth's orbit for the first time.
This was proved that space exploration doesn't have to be in the cell domain of
the state
in the 12 years since its first us groundbreaking success,
SpaceX accomplished over a hundred of successful launches and also delivered
tens of thousands of kilos of useful cargo,
both to the ISS from the earth and the other way round in total.
In addition since 2020,
the reusable spacecraft crude dragon has been on two successful flights to the
international space station, carrying astronauts on board.
It goes without saying that the SpaceX companies advancing by leaps and bounds.
One may debate the reasons of its dazzling success till the cows come home.
But this is rather pointless and done duly disrespectful.
Let's better direct our gay ahead into the future and envisage what fantastic
achievements where maybe looking to witness. As soon as the nearest decades,
SpaceX is currently working on three main tasks in space exploration.
First and foremost,
it is an international project of a man flight to the moon known as Artis,
which they're working on in collaboration with NASA, Issa Canada, Japan,
and a number of other countries also work is underway on the global satellite
internet constellation Starling that provides high speed satellite internet
access last but not least maned mission to Mars is currently in the pipeline.
The program Artemis aimed at exploring the moon was announced by the us
government in 2017.
It is suggested that the project is broken to down to at least three stages with
a start of the first one blend for the end of 2021,
it involves orbiting the Earth's natural satellite using an unmanned spacecraft
with its subsequent return to the earth. At the second stage,
a Crewe four astronauts is supposed to Orbi the moon without landing on it
at the third stage planned for 20 24,
4 astronauts are supposed to land on the surface of our earth. Satellite.
The upcoming mission to the moon may be seen as a practice run and the first
step to man flight to ours within the framework of the Artemis project,
the super heavy rocket booster and the SpaceX Starship will be tested in real
conditions. More river,
a space station has plans to be created in the moons orbit,
which may become a stopover platform for travelers bound for the red planet.
In the next 12 months,
SpaceX will have to launch ship spaceship to high and low altitude Orbis in
order to see how to adjust its construction to perfection.
These flights will include scheduled cargo delivery flights to the international
space station as well as launching communication satellites into the Earth's
Sobi eventually Starship is supposed toed.
The currently used Falcon nine and Falcon heavy rockets.
The new generation spacecraft will be able to boost up to a hundred tons of
payload into orbit within the course of one flight. Only at the same time,
the cost of one kilo of car is supposed to be at an all time. Low
Marz is at its closest point to the earth once every two years.
Obviously it makes sense to take advantage of the position of the planets as it
is the best and most convenient for traveling from one to the other.
The nearest time the planets will be their closest point is in the summer 2022.
This is when two unmanned cargo space ships are scheduled to be launched on a
way to the red planet.
It will take them from several months to one year to reached their destination.
Their mission will be to deliver around a hundred tons of cargo to the surface
of Mars, power, supply facilities, mining equipment, automated machinery,
and a lot more. The main objective at this stage will be to Reno,
to the ground,
to search for water ice and to take care of infrastructure for future colonists.
Remotely operable machinery will lay the groundwork for safe landings of future
crude missions. For example, it will need to clean the area from rocks,
which are potentially hazardous and to carry out a geological prospecting,
particularly focusing on finding water ice,
which is vital for future colonists survival,
and generally for developing a settlement water.
Isn't only a substance vital for any biological life forms,
but it's also indispensable in the electrolytic reaction that produces oxygen
and hydrogen as it transits cause the former is needed for breathing and for
burning fuel.
And the latter may be transformed into methane when coupled with CO2 methane
will be used as rocket fuel.
The following stage of Mars colonization is scheduled for 2024.
This is the next time.
Mars will be the shortest distance away from the earth to be more exact
approximately 57 million kilometers.
All in all four launches are planned two car flights and two man flights.
The spacecraft will travel for several months and reach their destination in
2025 shortly after they get some distance away from the earth,
it will be impossible to catch up with them.
So in case of unforeseen developments,
they will be left to their own devices with no assistance from the earth to
count on
spending several months on a flight and interplanetary space is quite a tough
audio. There are many important and complex tasks.
The constructives of the crude space ships will have to handle not only will the
available room have to be used as efficiently as possible,
but will also have to provide conditions good enough for the journey to be
comfortable and safe.
The expected number of the crew is several dozen people.
They will have both private quarters and common areas as well as gyms
to help prevent unwanted changes in their organisms.
That along stay in a weightless environment may cause in addition,
a large portion of the payload bay of the ship will be occupied by storage
rooms, various equipment and life support systems
protection from radiation is a crucial point in inter planet to travel.
As the rocket will be pointed in the direction opposite from the sun.
For most of the journey,
the living quarters are planned to be located in its front part,
thus the storage rooms and other sections not intended for the crew to in
permanently will be taking the brunt absorbing most of the harmful solar
radiation.
And so shielding the travelers from it,
the main goal for the red planet colonists will be to build up a Martian base
with adequate conditions where humans can stay prolonged periods that includes
creating favorable conditions for growing plants and deploying machinery and
equipment for producing oxygen and rocket fuel.
Even though it may sound rather fanciful Elon Musk claims to create a fully
fledged Martian colony by the end of next decade at the latest,
this colony should be able not only to remain autonomous for prolonged periods,
but also successfully develop. However,
the settlement on an alien planet may encounter unforeseen problems and suffer
from their dire consequences.
The project biosphere two is an example that illustrates just that within the
framework of this project,
a balanced biological system was supposed to be sustained under a sealed dome.
The experiment showed that creating an isolated ecosystem is an elaborate
process fraught with unforeseen in pitfalls.
The longer the short of it is that the performance of the ecosystem used in the
project. Wasn't up to the mark. As a result,
the system wasn't able to provide the potential settlers with either oxygen or
sufficient amounts of food.
Another danger to be reckoned with is cosmic radiation.
Mars is devoid of a magnetic field,
which would protect its serve is from cosmic craze.
That is why radiation protection should be higher.
The list of priorities when constructing the base even.
So there still remains a perceptible threat.
The Mars explorers are exposed to cosmic radiation may cause intoxication and
general weakening of the settlers organisms as well as raise the risk of getting
infected and developing tumors.
Another challenge that should be taken into account is psychological
compatibility or rather incompatibility of the colonists conflicts are to
be expected in an isolated community,
which is a well known phenomenon in psych ecology.
It's referred to as cabin fever or confined environment psychology,
which is manifested in heightened irritability of the members of an isolated
group.
Tempers become afraid for no apparent treason and the consequences may be grave
with the parties, fighting it out and even sustaining physical injuries.
Let's hope that ways will be found to handle this unpleasant phenomenon.
It is quite probable that first colonists will never have a chance of getting
back to their native planet disco.
Certainly Martian colonization is also likely to involve human casualties.
Still Elon Musk has made a pledge to develop the first Martian settlement into a
real city. By 2050,
this should be facilitated by the development of an interplanetary
transportation system,
which is something SpaceX claims to have in the pipeline as well.
Time will show whether it will work out or not.
Of course today talks about a Martian city,
have an error of science fiction about them,
but come to think of it just a hundred or even 50 years a ago,
talks of many things were now familiar with would appear to be flights of FCI.
Mankind is constantly forging ahead and new research results and discoveries are
announced by the scientific community every day.
That is why the chance to travel to Mars is real. If not for us,
then for our descendants.
But of course it's up to every individual to believe how big this chance
actually is. Let's keep in touch.
So.